well thank you for two marvelous
the most curmudgeonly theorist that ever
existed in a compelling way that is a
huge talent and I want to ask you about
Neil ISM just to start I'm gonna ask you
two questions and then I guess you'll
ask some questions Katie and we'll go on
from there and I think we'll have time
at a certain point to open it up oh yeah
so we'll see how that happens
so about Neil ISM which you said should
be thought with Weber as a condition not
an attitude it seems to me Neil ISM has
two possible vectors now one is the anti
foundationalist vector that you talked
about where in a sense if you say if we
recognize that we're coming from nowhere
values become plastic we can debate them
we can have an egg on in the public
sphere about them we can even create
values especially if you know that there
are no fixed or eternal values but the
second vector i think of neol ism is
apocalypticism which comes up in your
rhetoric and that would be the neol ism
of going nowhere what the anti
foundationalist move was always to open
up the future and D determine the future
now we're in a situation in which we're
struggling over how determined our
future is now but if it is fully
determined or close to fully determined
I'm not sure that the anti
foundationalist pose serves for this
that's my question in anti
foundationalism you can use nihilism
because without a foundation the future
is undetermined it brings a kind of want
of world as you called it to the center
but an apocalypticism where instrumental
reason hits this wall the wall it
created I'm not sure that that is
value-creating so that's my question
what do you do with apocalypticism in
this mode
if you're turning to nihilism to help us
through alright that's one question and
the second question is why values this
is a question really for you and your
broader thinking that would you were
gonna ask no but I just I just have
delighted that you're asking it okay and
I hate to make you pause for a sec okay
I made my classic move of bringing two
pens so that when one ran out of ink the
other one would serve and they both
apocalyptically collapsed on me thank
you
so why values yeah I know Weber is
emphasizing values and you're
experimenting with it mm-hm so I don't
mean to pin you to that but there are
other possibilities like concept
creation right in in a sense if you're
going to affirm something someone has to
say what it is you're affirming that
would be like a delusion response we can
create new concepts and then people can
affirm them but that's what you do in
the university not adjudicate values or
deconstructing the other would be just
the old standard utopias right instead
of values you kind of imagine a way the
whole world would be with all of the
problems that attend on that that's just
what came to mind but value associated
with mystery and the ineffable and the
irrational makes me ask that question
why values and not something else
those are my two kind of big questions
I'll name my two questions briefly and
then we'll riff a bit the two questions
are why does Wendy brown turn to Max
Weber does Wendy brown need Max Weber
and here I'm speaking Wendy brown is a
character a figure
I wager an icon why talk with Max Weber
and - what are we and here I want the
room to join into incredible Q&A last
night which concluded with a it's me
thrilling moment about the nature of
teaching in the modern University
and whether our pursuit of expertise
collaborates with the production of the
right kinds of classrooms in curricula
and so the way I would put that question
in the balled form would throughout your
tops the vocational is a problem my
colleague Michael Dunning raised
I thought thoughtfully a question that
was on my mind of is is vocational
problem you replied thoughtfully about
the nature of being at other
institutions where the aggression of
vocational it was much louder and
curricular reform so one
why does Wendy brown need to speak to
Max Weber so there's to me no doubt in
my mind that the return to classical
texts is a thing that we whose the we is
that this room is that this building the
people who made this building that
legislators return to classical texts
why they never tire of the return they
are renewable and they're a new ability
we teach ourselves how to think so
the easy answer Wendy Brown speaks to
Max Weber because she refuses a culture
of canceling and says I find something
in max that helps me Wendy articulate
louder something it had always been in
my thought but do we also then
participate in a reiteration of certain
forms of weakness that Wendy Brown does
not possess and insofar as I and I think
many in this room are working not really
to clean up the mistakes of our fathers
but also to forge new territories
further which your work both talks allow
us to do I do sometimes wonder
especially in the midst of the deep
critique of aber and he walked out of it
now Wendy to Katie I thought she doesn't
need him her both talks could have
functioned entirely from her own voice
her own story her own materials
and indeed if anything at times I
thought he brings her to a level that is
not hers so vocational I I'm you know my
primary identities as Americanist that's
a dangerous Imperial term we have
institutions of higher education in this
country for two reasons one is
Christianity and the other is a claim to
vocation so the story that we tell about
arts is a very important and powerful
story but it is one resuscitated from
dirtier origins so until is we well know
on this stage but I think we all until
the Civil War there were no
non-christian institutions of higher
education in this country the merchants
of the so-called land-grant institution
was a plot to territorial eyes the West
overtly in the Morrill Act to create
agricultural education for agriculture
engineering science and teachers so
training teachers and training
agricultural thinking that is the work
of settler colonial ands was essential
to the formation of the land-grant
public university the story of liberal
arts emerges from that since there's a
great little clause in the moral app
that says you know not to the detriment
of course of classical day and say of
course of classical education so the
moral axle want to protect classical
education yet the only institutions of
higher education that existed before
1850 that care deeply practice deeply
classical education are the University
of South Carolina University of Georgia
University of North Carolina everyone
here knows these were also practices of
trying to legitimate white supremacy
through the forms of classical means so
we arrived now all of us at the 21st
century meet a defender of the lib arts
but what's the history of that liberal
arts that we all that we value I would
argue it's a history 1972 to 1998 we
have to get past the Civil Rights Act we
have to get past title 9 you have to get
to a place where actually those
institutions are genuinely fighting to
be democratic and the myth we have of a
post-war land-grant institution filled
with people studying non-vocational
things is I think strongly empower flee
a myth so there is though a powerful 20
year history of land-grant institutions
being the sources of as you put
creativity vitality it's a critique but
I wonder sometimes if the history that
we have for the non-vocational is
limited it's a Boomer story and we would
do well to think about how as you
powerful in your answer to QA what is
the curriculum for democracy rather than
a curriculum that is and this is not
your language by worry about it being
circulation against vocation since I
think location is deep in the financial
institutional waters that we swim don't
you want to just keep listening to her
we'll try to make that happen first
thank you both it's an enormous honor
and pleasure to be working with these
two
I think we really are going to have a
conversation so let me start with Paul's
division of nihilism into its post
foundationalist possibilities and
promise the openings versus
apocalypticism and take a step back from
those choices and say something else it
seems to me that what weber leaning on
nietzsche means by thinking nihilism as
a condition is that it's a peculiarly
Western historical predicament that
comes from having founded truth
Authority order and everything else in
monotheism and that it is not that as
soon as anybody stops having religious
authority or other kinds of authorities
understood to be above history outside
the human world as Nietzsche puts it
that everything wobbles in the way that
Nietzsche describes his story is a is a
story of I'm going to say
judeo-christian and though I don't
usually use the term because he takes so
seriously that Christianity comes out of
Judaism so it's a particular story about
the predicaments of meaning once
monotheistic Authority crashes and a
particular story about the conceits of
science in that displacement so I am not
convinced that the so-called post
foundationalist retort to this problem
that's a little stronger response to
this problem which is okay now we know
we make meaning we even make the meaning
of meaning and so now we just the
political solution is to just do it
right really gets at the depth and the
problematic that the collapse of a
particular source of meaning and its
continued devastation
by the conceits of science all you can
know is what's true about the world you
can't know how to value or rank value
even with climate change science you
have to decide if you want a world you
have to decide if you prefer to have a
future over contemporary continued ways
of life and I don't think that's just
about the real creeps and and fossil
fuels industry I think we're all
deciding that every day I think that's
part of how we live the predicament of
something like knowledge about a climate
emergency you think well I really want
that vacation I know I'm not supposed to
fly but my family's been dreaming of
going to the Himalayas forever and we're
just gonna do it and then we'll think
about this other problem later and I
actually think that the whole
predicament of the relationship to the
truth of facticity that Weber gives us
and the problematic of value that that
usurpation of value by the rise of
fective city without the ability to
establish or rank value is in his mind
because in Nietzsche's mind because he
lies so heavily on Nietzsche a
distinctly Western predicament and a
distinctly late modern Western
predicament now that said I do think
that today the that I just will add
that's why I think Nietzsche and then
Weber spend so much time on the question
of what happens to value that it doesn't
just disappear it grows you know trivial
or instrumental or branded or fungible
or tradable traffic Abul rather than
just vanishing and that too is peculiar
to that history that said I I do think
that the possibility that and this is
beginning to answer your both of your
questions about why Weber
that Weber offers is one parallel to the
hubber machine one okay now now we have
to figure out what to value but that
Weber really places it in a more
[Music]
political distinctly political frame by
saying that is where we will settle
value it's not that it's going to be
settled in the classroom or the
philosophers study or in deliberation or
in consensus or anything else it's
really going to be about putting value
out there and making it attractive and
that's why it gets attached scarily to
charisma and at the same time that's
where we will foreground that struggle I
I find that part of Faber's thinking
really worth thinking with on the left I
think we have allowed that formulation
to be scarily framed as Hitlerian
mussolini ich but also the project that
you see in our current Attorney General
that was confessed openly a week and a
half ago that what the real task of the
US now is is to simply restore Christian
values to legislation adjudication and
all of culture but I don't think it's
just it belongs with the right and I
think that the left has a tendency to
believe that rationality or institutions
or procedural ism or simply the rule of
law is is what will rescue us or simply
reckoning with facts and I I think to
begin to answer the why Weber question I
think he's telling us over and over
again no that's not how politics works
but that's not also where we are at the
point at which we cannot root value in
those things those are the that's the
world that
um well can you know can continue to be
important at a so-called scientific
level but it's not the place where we
will decide who we are how do we live
what do we value what's our relationship
to one another to the earth and and and
to the things we think we need as a as a
collectivity as it were now that said
there is this I'm gonna move off of
question one soon or I will not leave
any room for anything else there is this
problem of apocalypticism and I do think
that for many that's the piece of the
nihilistic condition combined with the
fact that we actually seem to be staring
into a very immediate potential for for
total darkness that is that is the piece
of the nihilistic predicament that that
many have either in their hearts or are
driven by and I alluded to that and some
of the kind of will to nothingness that
I think we see in some of the right I
concluded my last book with the argument
that there's a certain part of wounded
white male supremacy that simply says
you know if if we don't rule the planet
there will be no planet if we don't rule
democracy there will be no democracy I
do think that we see that current and
that surge in in the present and I think
that needs to be sort of taken on board
and dealt with and I do think that
apocalypticism you know it hangs out in
in hearts that are not necessarily
right-wing as well I don't think it's an
inevitable entailment of the nihilistic
predicament simply because it's it's it
can be broken off from the question of
whether we have certain predicaments of
meaning today that require us to make
decisions and engage in struggles for
what we value what we love what we have
decide to affirm
there's much more to say about that I
think we could have hours on this topic
but I'll leave it there on the question
of y-values yeah weber did lead me down
a path here because i don't really
believe in the histories i don't let me
put it this way
one of labor's big fights as most people
know is with a marxist materialism and
there's a much more materialist strain
in my thinking than weber would tolerate
and a much more Foucauldian strain in my
thinking that weber would tolerate
neither of them would have any use for
this idea of values but what do I think
weber has rescued here the idea that
there is always some value even if it's
a terribly depleted weak and anemic
value in the Machinery's that dominate
us they're not just ideological that is
for example capitalism neoliberalism
forms of moral traditionalism that
governed today they're not just
ideological they're they're they're
actually in I mean Weber is the one who
gives us the concept of political
rationality that Foucault then makes so
much of there's forms of value in
organized operations of rationality by
which we live today and the only way to
contest those is with counter values so
I I don't I I can't go all the way with
Weber on values but I think he's onto
something that disappears from both the
marxist and Foucauldian approaches to
history and power and what governs us
that I would otherwise use they do not
have to be associated with mystery
ineffability theology and so forth
though I think what Weber is reminding
us is they will always have when they're
powerful some
either reactive or erotic or other
attachment that is not reducible to
rational deliberation so this is my
pushing off pushing away from the harbor
Massey an attempt to give us new
normative orders now why mocks Weber
so last night at a dinner I confessed
that it won't be a very exciting
confession that had I not fallen in love
with political theory at a very young
age probably my own political passions
would be much less circuitous and
mediated through canonical political
writers and studies of text and probably
just be more ways of reading the
contemporary world and while arguing for
what was wrong with it and declaring
what we need to do and in some ways I'm
oh I'm often aware of this when I'm
teaching I realized that I'm forcing
students through the same path often
without the same ardour fruit for the
Canon that I took in order to arrive at
something like well the Liberty takes
this form but it also takes this form
and look if you think over here with
Marx you realize that emancipation is
really different from what mill means by
liberty and that looks over there like
just an individual thing where you're
just navigating the conditions of life
and Marx says here you know we really
need to seize those conditions and shape
them ourselves and that's where freedom
rests and to do that we struggle with on
the Jewish Question and we struggle with
Mills subjection of women and would go
through all this difficulty and we could
just cut through it so what do we do
with this fact that we scholars many of
us were drawn to the fields the texts
the study that we do for reasons that we
might call
aesthetic erotic intellectual and we
have political motivations and
animations that we attach to that and we
try to do it responsibly so we're not
simply becoming textual dogmatists or
pedagogical dogmatist but kind of
circuitous and maybe we need lessly
layered route and particularly with
somebody like weber so I think that's
true I think that is like a little bit
of the madness of what we do and maybe
even you know if we're gonna be really
rough on ourselves maybe even the
wastefulness of what we do however what
I have gotten from teaching weber and
encountering weber year after year is an
encounter with a deeply conservative
thinker who might also admire and what i
have also gotten from thinking with
weber is an encounter with somebody who
has as much passion for knowledge and as
much passion for politics and the
redemption of the political realm as any
other thinker or human i know this is
how one ends up with one's dead
interlocutors I know him and I feel like
my thinking is sharpened and cultivated
and cultured at that site because of the
encounter with the conservatism I have
to really think through what do I want
to value and affirm and cherish of that
what do I want to lean away from what do
I want to build from how do I want to
modify it and also I have to really
think through that knowledge politics
relation I you know I think many of us
are often at some kind of odds with our
super PC colleagues or students our
conservative colleagues or students
we're trying to
keep alive a kind of intellectual
openness curiosity availability to the
novel to the new avoid having political
programs and dicta dominate what we do
or how we think but at the same time
trying to honor that there is no neutral
knowledge that you can't read the moral
act as simply having brought us that but
I won't do all of that again you did it
beautifully so that's where Weber really
helps me um that you know it's like
we're we're so helps me not be the kind
of Marxist that I was in my youth where
I really thought it was me that
materialism in in a in a in an expansive
economic sense that included
reproductive and productive life and all
the rest of it was what mattered and
then I encounter I think they're like
we're so and I think no there's also
this other really important realm for
freedom and collective
self-determination it's a political
realm it's not subsume Abul to the
material to the economic it it's it is
the place where we have to think out
sovereignty self-determination but also
the question of difference how what we
do when we when we disagree and you know
again I'm gonna end where I started
probably I could do it some other way I
don't think I'd do it as well now then
the question is does that matter is this
just a scholar satisfaction oh I've
really gotten all the subtleties on to
the page but it hasn't really helped the
world much of that what's the politics
of that so sometimes I I haven't done it
yet but I've thought about trying to
teach classes that aren't political
theory at all like how do we reconcile
democracy and climate change which I
think there's a really hard problem how
do we deal with the fact that democracy
is probably not the domain that will
give us a
and chance at this planet it's going to
have to happen from supervenient powers
by supervenient I don't mean godly I
mean of something above democratic
deliberation and elections and so forth
and it's going to have to happen in some
hardcore enforceable way what and that's
just a preliminary thought and I thought
about trying to just teach classes a
class where I just try to have students
and me think through that problem
without doing it through all these kinds
of mediations it's a little scary for me
it's because it's it's a little bit you
know these are our approach errs these
are these these these are our security
blankets but that tells me that probably
we ought to try and one seems that was
that was what I heard yeah conclusion of
yesterday yes how our aperture is
keeping us from creating from fulfilling
a democratic purpose for these
institutions but I want to get in
stepped before I do I want it do you
want to say about this isn't no I'd like
to say something about old text yeah
since it's the only thing I ever do so
I'm like the extreme version of one side
of you what I hear you so I always
gather from you this great motivation
for going back to the vapors and the
Plato's and the Machiavelli's because in
some sense the world in especially in
its mediatic form it narrows you to a
set of arguments that are that seem a
movable and someone might come up with
another position but it's always kind of
dialectical visa avi those positions
left right but once a text has been
cancelled and become recondite and it's
clearly not of our age it becomes a
source for things that we wouldn't have
thought of because the texts as you've
shown with Weber so brilliantly are much
bigger than our caricatures of them that
we use to bolster our our opinions so I
see you discovering nobody wants to go
back and become of a Marian
there are people who are vey barians and
we don't invite them to give Tanner
lecture
but that's not what you're doing you're
finding the to quote Heidegger the parts
of the past that were unthought even in
Weber and that speak to us from afar and
you do that consistently in all of your
books you bring these messages from afar
out of their context and they wake you
up so that's my spirited defense of what
you do does that sound that says let me
now make a polemical point probably
offend one person in this room what has
happened in my field to the history of
political thought with the adamant
Cambridge school and it's cousins style
of historicism that what we are doing in
the history of political thought is
trying to get the context right so that
we get the meaning right so that we
really understand what's going on there
has nearly destroyed the kind of thing
that I am trying to do with political
theory and that many of those initially
drawn to political theory want to do to
it I think literature has has more poly
vocality in its approaches that's at
least looks that way to me from where I
sit
but the conquest has been nearly
complete in in that field and people who
do the kind of thinking I do are
supposed to just be doing so-called
contemporary political theory or what is
usually called normative political
theory without this kind of what one of
my colleagues referred to as amateurish
my name of the camp canonical texts
amateurish because why because I didn't
master the Weber literature because I
don't know all the German history
because I'm not doing all the work in
the original language because I am not
simply reconciling one piece of Weber
stock with another but bringing all
kinds of contemporary concerns to it and
taking what I want and leaving the rest
and so when I was arguing
yesterday for breaking out of these
silos that's some of the kind of silos
and I'm insisting on breaking out of
yeah long live the amateur well it's a
tricky thing to say right because we're
looking at graduate yeah well this is I
think but this is the challenge of the
politics of these institutions which of
course I'm especially interested in that
challenge are these institutions the
site for future thinking for democracy
or are they not so - what role do with
these institutions play since I think so
important a question the mesmerise ation
of expertise we have to admit is
throttling all of us such that my guess
is most of the people in this room and I
here because of Wendy Brown political
theorist only know about political
science departments but because they
precisely saw you as insurgent on those
terms as amateur on those terms so that
they could access the work and when you
say I got from Weber
that's not how politics work and that
there's values even if they're terribly
weak and anemic and all machinery I got
that from Wendy Brown I've read all the
favor I didn't get that from favor I got
that from Wendy Brown
so the extent of discovery in the text
is usually a mirror image of self you
find the thing that resonates and then
you create Brotherhood there's no doubt
that's the dream of the college seminar
that we would teach great works and that
briefly we with the students we what
subordinate are crazy daily selves and
realize in the wisdom of the text played
up Conte Toni Morrison oh the enormity
of other souls that is a beautiful model
I I think we all they're probably large
consensus that's a model to fight for is
that happening in these institutions or
the expertise it takes to get into that
room yeah is canceling the capacity to
truly create a free room and and let me
add that the criteria for excellence
which means appointments tenure
promotion and the rest are precisely
criteria that reject the amateurish ness
precise criteria only I mean that's why
I'm trying to address the graduate
students in the room they know that they
know they can't do what I did they
cannot give the lecture I gave yeah and
expect to get a job so that we all seem
as hypocrites and then
you say you face a classroom that's
asking why should I subordinate to these
texts when to be able to do this is both
ask you to silence such large parts of
myself and in the end what will I get
for that self sublime and it's not
speaking to the world right which is the
thing that we think we want to do it's
the thing Weber prohibited but that's
where that's where he's also helpful for
me I mean I'm thinking about okay that
prohibition is really deep he won that
prohibition that you work on you are a
scholar scholar I mean the prohibition
against you know engaging world mixing
in your own aspirations and fears and
reactions into your scholarship and
thinking through a text with it with the
kind of admixture of all of that in
order to bring something to the world in
order to bring something to students so
we are educating for a democracy that's
that's what he prohibited and that
prohibition is so deep in the Academy it
is so deep so part of what I was arguing
for at the very end was to struggle
against that and I know it's not easy
because interestingly enough even among
the three of us up here we still have
our little noses in the air when it
comes to our judgment of scholarship and
it's not it's you know we're still
looking for does this person really know
her Kafka or she making [ __ ] up okay
okay I want to say just one more thing I
have just a tiny quarrel with you about
the moral yeah you know it better than I
do I want to just argue about your
dating for a second which is you said
you know the only real moment we get
this high quality mass public higher
education is 1972 until the
neoliberalism closet I feel like you're
forgetting the post-war period I have
strong feelings about that period let's
get into it let's do it you wanna see
the GI comes home yeah I mean it's a
very particular moment and what I want
the Civil Rights Act to come in it's who
were in those rooms i underst
and so far as freedom for me I don't
deny that there is a great deal of
nostalgia for a particular experience
but I'm interested in the challenge of
that when the room is genuinely are
reaching for true democracy which it
really wasn't from 45 to 72 in my strong
demographic intellectual opinion but I
don't deny that many people in many
people in this room were taught in those
classrooms have a memory of them I just
want to remind them as I know you do in
your work who was there what capacity
was there just feel differently about
comp what kind of questions were being
raised about Kafka it's a part of us
even in the curriculum at that point
there were all engineers in that period
and also then the vocational was not
disconnected from the GI Bill and so
insofar as the deepest claim I I want to
make us something about it and the
vocation will be aligned with democracy
mm-hmm more than I think absolutely as
you know Citizen forever of the state of
Wisconsin at the heart of the question
at the end of the day at the same time
those occasions were all teachers
colleges and agricultural colleges and
it was seen that to be a teacher to be
an engineer to be it was also tied up
with democracy are the what are the
right curriculum for that is Weber the
right curriculum for that in twenty
nineteen twenty thirty nine I think I
would I want to line the interests of a
course the worker the the vocational
alongside the praise of democracy and
democracy that really ties in with
another of my questions on my list which
is what is Wendy Browns University what
is the curriculum the Brown University
[Laughter]
new Brown University I know that's
really an unfair question but well it's
interesting it's not an entirely unfair
question when in the late 90s the
university of california saw this huge
population bulge coming and also
understood that it would be majority
non-white and before the crash of the
2000s the recession followed by the
financial crisis a new campus was to be
founded and it was the University of
California at Merced which most of you
haven't heard of and it's in the Central
Valley it's in a relatively poor part of
the Central Valley it's in a part of the
Central Valley that once was our
agricultural heartland and also an
industrial heartland most of the
industries were so heavily Pulu
that they've been moved over the border
into Mexico and agriculture lives on but
in a different way
and it's now the meth capital of
California so that's where the new
University was being dropped and a
shadow Senate was formed a Faculty
Senate because it didn't have faculty
yet when it was gonna be built and I was
lucky enough to be a representative on
that Senate there were 10 of us and our
task was to design a new University and
we had fantastic ideas we were going to
combine educating for democracy with
educating populations most of whom were
first-generation and many of whom would
be from migrant families but most of
whom even if they weren't even if they
were white working-class hadn't been to
college before with the understanding
that this university campus was going to
be treated by the system of you see as
the stepchild we knew it we knew it from
the beginning we could smell it we could
see it we knew all the reasons that was
going to be the case it wasn't even
going to have a library it was going to
use interlibrary loan so that Berkeley
and Davis and UCLA would be but we still
thought we could do something exciting
we were going to do it by building in
building clusters of knowledge and
teaching that had that represented
disciplines so that people could still
get tenure in their discipline but we're
not exclusively disciplinary and we also
understood that problems would shift
would change and that vocations would
shift and change so we built in a light
kind of fluidity
I won't go further but I will say that
our beautiful architecture of this new
College at the level of intellect was
eliminated by the first president in
favor of
the most vocational in the classic sense
University of California campus where
teaching and a teaching school not even
called an education school is important
as is engineering but as is also a
series of things that have to do with
the construction trades and other things
it's pretty much a four-year Community
College and we were told explicitly as
we were designing this thing Latinos
don't want to learn Shakespeare
we were told explicitly that building in
literature and poetry and critical
theory and all kinds of other things and
also building programs that would allow
for the possibility of explicitly
political development that was one of
our constellations was just silly what
was going to be wanted by these this
student population were practical
vocations and an education that would
produce it so all I'm doing is ending on
a more critical note but I don't have
and you know this is not something one
person figures out and and I think what
we're also expressing up here is a ton
of ambivalence we all love our fields no
we don't love our disciplines we all
love the things that drew us into them
and we also all know that that might not
be quite right for this moment but we
also don't want to become sort of
flat-footed ly urgent about the moment
in such a way that we think oh what we
must do is solve problems and teach
civics and the value of a constitution
and why democracy really matters and
what it really involves and what
inclusion really involves and forget all
the rest of that stuff because we know
to do that well to be those kinds of
citizens you also need to be a
historical historically minded person
you need to understand this present
isn't the only present and this present
has historical determinants to teach
that you can't just say it you have to
deep students in it so that's where
we're I think deeply ambivalent
should we go here absolutely okay I know
that was sudden but
I of course was working on microbes as I
want people to come forward and speak I
think about who produced that president
of UC Merced we are we there was the
demographics about university leadership
still are with important incursions my
schools of business are still
predominantly PhD to people so insofar
as these institutions have a concept of
variable faculty leadership variable to
what extent do we incorporate as a part
of our self making ideas of these sorts
of conversations since I'm interested
that I've no doubt there are any
political forces that influence the
transformation of your utopia in yes
ality but I could imagine multiple
different kinds of persona identified in
that role who would have taken different
you want us to just keep talking no okay
is just to make people want to read it
and I always feel like this stuff I read
this like you made me go back and read
this is a very quickly in the last
couple of days and two thoughts have
come out of this conversation and that
one is maybe get the microphone just a
little closer to your tall self one one
thing that comes out is that those last
comments about Merced were to my mind
closer to much of what Weber was doing
in science of vocation than lots of the
rest of it because he actually is
talking about the state of the
universities a fascinating account of
the difference between the American
University of a German university and
that question of kind of what is the
nature of a university with not just the
theoretical and abstract issues but the
vital issues even talks about salaries
of assistant professors in that essay
that made that that I was so glad that
you gave us that account of the versed
thing and but it doesn't so that goes
back I
to the question I asked a little bit
yesterday which is whether one could
imagine a more positive sense of a
vocational education if indeed there is
a more powerful sense perhaps it is my
apostate Catholicism and my apostate
communism that thinks that liberal arts
education isn't the end of an
educational imagination but education
for real callings for the dignity of
different callings for crafts that would
include the diss the vocation of being a
musician
the vocation of being a caregiver that
could break the SSAT monopoly of the
vision of liberal education so that's
one thought second thought be very quick
the other thing that he starts with I
was struck by you ended with last night
is actually the tension between scholar
and teacher yes that these are not the
same thing and there really is and I
just wondered it seemed to me that the
question of the relation of politics is
different for scholars than for teachers
yes
very powerfully I agree entirely with
his idea that we should not be political
people in the lecture room as
translation that I read is that we are
not holding we're not leaders we are
teachers and that's a different thing
the question of whether or not values
politics all of those things have a
place in scholarship is a different kind
of question I think than in teaching one
that he's doesn't answer for me and I
wondered if you had thoughts on that
for him real scholarship also cannot
have values politics in it because the
the study of the facts comes to an end
that said what's striking about his
corpus is how many so-called occasional
papers
not to mention political papers comprise
that corpus he's he's
oh he's eager to set out his views on
all kinds of things as long as they're
demarcated the way they are in the
vocations lectures themselves as values
projects rather than as scholarly
projects but here I would join you in
saying that one could honor vapers own
understanding of why it's inappropriate
for us to pull Emma sighs in the
classroom or even push in a either overt
or covert way our own political values
or other values without identifying them
as such you know you know if we say we
can't strip them out we know that we
know better than that but everything's
an interpretation blah blah blah that
even then then it needs to be identified
as such but I think one could see Weber
as making that argument largely because
of what he calls the inegalitarian ism
of the classroom we sit here the
students sit there we speak they're mute
I know that supposedly less the case in
seminars but we still know what the
power relations are and he did too
whereas in one's writing one is writing
making an argument and others can
encounter it by arguing back so it's a
very different order of things a very
different relationship to the problem of
power in our writing leaving aside the
question in our research in our writing
than in our teaching so I think one one
could make that testing
that said I find it interesting that
most of us in this room I suspect have
more respect for academic work in the
humanities and let's just called the
human sciences interpretive social
sciences and the humanities and arts
more respect for a work that really
tries to grapple with its object then
work that precedes the object with its
view its value its polemic and so forth
we know what we have to say about that
kind of stuff we don't like it we tell
our students not to do it we we we
discount it when we're doing evaluations
of other people's research and so forth
we don't like it when people lead with
their values we like it when they work
things out through the object that
they're analyzing even if we bring
certain questions and certain prejudices
and certain interests and and and
certain animating purposes to the work
so I still think there's some some
interval that's why I got tried to get
rid of the opposition but some interval
that most of us are somewhat interested
in that I think we're probably also
interested in democratic debate we want
people to think about the problem before
them and learn from it not simply come
charging in with what they're quite sure
of how do you conceive of your
relationship between I guess knowledge
production in power and do you think
that's sort of after that a revolution
or sort of like radical action can
really even be incited from within the
institution itself and it's not a part
of your scholarly project is that
something you guys care about I think
that's also what you're you're asking
and thank you for that question I mean
you put it in a very compressed way and
as usual we elaborated
oh you know I think the simple answer
that that to your question is no this is
not you know there's too much vested
interest in our position security ways
habits institutional attachments lovely
modes of life to imagine that this is
the source of such things that said I've
never been opposed to the idea of split
personalities as long as they're they're
not really injurious and dangerous to
the psyche forget that sentence what I
mean is I think it's one thing for us to
know that and acknowledge that and
another thing to have as our purpose in
the classroom to open up this world and
allow it to be a place for students to
be incited by what they learn and desire
from that place a different world that
said what some of my undergraduates
resist in my own pedagogy cuz I know I'm
on the left and then I'm always saying
wait wait wait wait wait we're not
making revolution here we're trying to
figure things out this is where we
figure things out and they say but let's
cancel class and go do the little uh and
because we're always having strikes at
Berkeley for this and that and it's like
cancel class you don't understand there
are like 15 seconds left to a liberal
arts education don't cancel this thing
this is the last place you have to
actually sit and think and learn and
deliberate and expand what you know and
believe and think the trajectory of the
world could be might be and so forth
this is where we do that there's tons of
room beyond this hour and a half twice a
week to act this this should not be our
organizing site so you know you're
seeing the split personality my eye I
want them to be doing that and I
participate in it myself and at the same
time I think that the place for thinking
and mowing and deliberating and
reflecting and and and criticizing and
rethinking what one knows and learning
new stuff and and changing one's angle
of vision that that's that's at best
what universities can before and and
that we mustn't join the rush on the
part of the right to eliminate that
space by being complicit with it in our
own political urgency I feel like a
graduate student in your class so I'm
gonna propose this and you can tell me
what you think about it speaking to your
issue and especially to your friend who
I know has a similar concern I want to
propose a case thinking back to the the
GI Bill and the University there and the
role of a classical education or reading
old texts there I think it's very
different at this moment than it was
then and the case I want to propose to
you but I don't think we're there yet I
think even this very debate or thinking
belongs the Academy and acting belongs
to is part of the fact that we're not
sufficiently neoliberal i's din the
university enough hear me out for the
classical text to be such a huge
political act that it is the point of
resistance and the case i'm thinking of
as chile which i now know a lot about
during the dictatorship which was the
neoliberal ization of the country they
just blew out all the classical
education in the universities and it all
became vocational it was all every ounce
of it was set up to build a kind of a
score a kind of a credit to give you a
leg up in this giant market including
the real estate value of the land on
which the university was but some people
got together and founded an underground
university in which they read these
texts and it was open to anybody and the
people who came were resisting through
not through learning to think critically
but even knowing that there was a
position outside number one and texts
they were teaching only critical texts
in which all of these questions were
being were up for grabs in a sense
vapers a little bit different than that
because it's the way he speaks at
least in these lectures are so
authoritative yeah you think there's no
problems with it it's like this it's
like this it's like this but for the
most part he's contending with severe
problems just the idea that you could by
talking by thinking contend with
problems in an age like that is huge but
we're not there yet we still think we
could that tradition in its traditional
way some people think this could carry
us forward or throwing it out could
carry us forward so am i arguing for
more neoliberalism at Yale no but you
are arguing for these alternative spaces
you are arguing clearly for not just
thinking about the Academy versus the
public square but instead I mean which
we saw of course in Occupy all these
study groups and you know when you're
sitting in a tent in the middle of Wall
Street you have nothing but time on your
hands especially if your phone can't be
charged so you want texts and a lot of
that happened right we've been reading
moated and Hardy's undercommons and
thinking about how to have spaces inside
of this beast to do that the only thing
I would add is we haven't begun to test
these institutions to see if they what
they can do yes people in them liked
these wood walls I've gotten involved in
my building projects now these are
shitty walls they can be very quickly
destroyed what looks solid was sometimes
made with great care and foresight but
she's not telling you to destroy the
walls no well don't and so far as part
of creating new spaces I'm always
interested and students have a different
power than faculty financially
prospectively imposing certain
weaknesses back to them and I have
certainly fought this institution which
I did not imagine being at the extent to
which claims of strength this is as if
it was any research shows was a very
recent past a conjurer and the greatness
of an intellectual before about a 30
year his
you look at the scholarly record of
dollars at Yale 1960s embarrassing
embarrassing and yet we are the place
that incarnate sand protects excellence
I know why I can tell the history of why
we do that and why we think we do
relative to a 300-year history but it's
because you've been in it not because
we'd necessarily found a way we've been
able to allure a lot of views into it
because of wood walls that can quickly
be resurfaced changed with a little bit
of and then a little bit of resistance
back from us because we have to stay
here afterwards and clean up and put the
seats back together and create what the
classroom again so we have to perform
overall as strategists and protectors
and you have to perform your role as
tactician and resistor and please let
that to not stop and the extent to which
faculty have been a little dull on the
job because the pleasures are so great
intellectual and material it's being
able to think full-time we are complicit
and not seeing that we too could do a
little more to say we decide who gets
tenure every day and that can change
[Laughter]
[Applause]
maybe we want how long does this run
where's Gary do we want more he left oh
why don't we take these last two
questions together I mean not at the
same time but one at a time and then
we'll wrap up so yeah I first I want to
say this is crazy because I thought
there were few merits left to being here
and then I found the poster for this
conversation and I was like this is
something I want to be on I really
appreciate the conversation that was
just had but I have to confess that it
does make me uncomfortable because two
years ago when I got here I would have
wanted to create that alternative space
at the University I would have wanted to
transform every single classroom space
into that and into its revolutionary
potential but and I have to confess that
I that because I spent time in an occupy
tents not on Wall Street but
space where people took time out of the
place that other people were excluded
from to be in front of a building and
then sit and and let people that they
had never met before who they don't know
where they sleep just interrupt them in
conversation about their politicization
of of the future I know who is missing
in our classrooms like there are people
that are just not there and for us to
sit in classrooms and think that that we
can engage with these texts and in a way
that is responsible with consenting to
the systematic exclusion of certain
people as much as I am devoted and I and
I respect all three of you so much for
this devotion to careful intellectualism
believing that there is a manaat' sought
that we did leave behind I'm constantly
just thinking about the people who are
not there and so when I think about the
call that my grandmother makes about
like whether I will go to grad school
and I'm when I'm thinking about my 12
year-old brother and how when he wants
to go to undergrad the world will not be
normal
I'm just thinking like can we wait I
don't know a single revolutionary that
decided to do what they did because they
felt ready we'll leave that to Professor
Brown no we're gonna take both okay
thank you for that question common
because I think it kind of fits in
really well to the question that I left
thinking last night and it's very
present in the discussion today but I
left last night thinking about the role
that the expert plays in knowledge
especially the concept of expert or
expertise as the owners the the people
who get to claim ownership of this
knowledge of this position in politics
of like how do we reconcile this
creation of expertise when it's so very
much frames itself especially in the you
know
versity as like we are the thinker's we
are the possessors of knowledge and
weather how does that play with
information when a lot of the ways in
which we gain access is not necessarily
proving that we have knowledge but
rather that we were able to retain
enough information to pass the SAT to
pass the GREs like these like so both
the role of the expert and knowing that
the institution institutionalisation the
professionalization of the ownership of
knowledge and it's completely complicit
and affected by the oppression and
exclusion of non experts and we see this
in social justice as well of like lay
people becoming citizen scientists
because scientists are the ones who get
to create knowledge but what does the
citizen science or the amateur which is
something maybe even better than the
citizen because citizen reflects like
there are people who are in who are
doing this work who are not citizens
rejecting the legal term in expert and
using amateur instead yeah just
something more of the to think about but
really that role in all of this thank
you
I would just say one thing to begin my
nerdiness is grounded a thing that is
very little to do with what I teach
I love sectarianism I love really
obscure conflicts over when you put the
baby's head in the water
all day long I want to do that all day
long she doesn't want to put the baby's
head it was just one of those Grammatik
she liked but but insofar as that
tradition of obsessiveness has given me
the right to then say this I then joined
the question of expertise what pleasure
does that give so I'm about to say
something I I imagine might be soothing
or not to you but I am I am mind it's
very soothing but it is based on the
question that deep learning all of a
sudden you come into these everyone this
room has had this oh my god if everyone
knew that they feel a little less what
history of religions is filled with
basically one thing don't forget the
dead don't forget the dead
don't forget the dead that's the thing
that links every form of tradition
whatever probably isn't might be there
don't forget
the missing the missing is different
than the dead but I think for me the
powerful presence of a socially
engineered classroom which puts you in
it
this was by design you are here it's
only a ten year old history at Yale that
we designed you to be here was not so
that you forgot although let's be clear
the 20th century history of this
institution was absolutely assimilate
your Jew you're a Catholic become us you
know wasp is amazing we have such fun of
block islands you don't want to be that
person
and we now socially engineer to a world
if students were like I don't want your
conversion I'm gonna be me and I want to
remember everyone who doesn't get a
piece of this right I think there are
traditions of knowledge and thought they
have also told you don't forget ritual
eyes their remembrance how do you do
that we can have some talks and I think
expertise gives us a resource but let's
be clear expertise is always a posture
in the room that everyone's like a break
every time Kevin Cruz is along the read
correcting the historicity of
legislators a little embarrassed I think
they don't care Kevin they don't care
but then we value expertise why I think
because we know that somewhere someone
is trapping all the humanity that is
lost and forgotten to what end
I then lead to the philosophers
I gonna say something simpler
while respecting that you you got it
right you absolutely got it right I
think that the difficulty of a developed
political consciousness while one is
inside the Academy is that it shapes not
just against the wrongs of the way the
Academy is organized but the very idea
of continuing to be here when there is a
world to save
and I don't know that this is going to
be soothing in the least because chafing
is not is very uncomfortable but I think
that it's probably worth it
to live with that including the I'm here
but my sisters and brothers aren't I'm
here but there's a world excluded I'm
here but it demands assimilation being a
wasp is great I'm here but I know that
deep corruptions of this institution
manifest at the law school meltdown last
year I'm here but I need to be out where
the world is maybe it helps to think
about Ocasio Cortez who is a shining
light for us right now because she got
an education she also happens to have
spirit and Verve and God and charisma
and guts but that analytic thing she's
got going could not have been short she
could not have involved a short
circuiting of these kinds of moments
where you put it all together or the
moments that I'm not saying it was a
perfect education I'm not saying that
this is a defensive education but I do
think that what
what one can get from thinking maybe I
was in that there and and then I'll say
this a part of me continues to chafe and
and lunge toward the world and as I
approach retirement which I'm gonna do
next year I am still undecided about
whether I'm gonna continue to have a
relationship at all with the Academy or
whether I'm going to try to take this
voice and put it directly into political
movements and political agitation
because there's a world at stake and I
feel like I've had a really good ride
and what I want to make sure is that I
give back everything I can now I'll tell
you what's interesting whenever I try
that out including with my students that
oh no we need you in the classroom
oh no we need you in the Academy this is
where you wake people up this is it and
I think that tension and I'm not saying
this is about you know me in particular
I'm saying that tension of what happens
inside educational institutions at their
best if we can think properly about how
to reorganize them how to press against
their limitations how to deal with that
problem of expertise which we both want
about certain things and reject about
certain things and that too is attention
I mean the educational system is broken
but that doesn't mean it's just about
getting rid of the experts just as the
medical system is broken and we all rely
on it and try to find our ways to the
experts I think that with mmm
The Economist's are really interesting
to me right now because they're the
experts of experts of experts and only a
tiny number of them are willing to say
oops about what they brought us to over
the last thirty years but that tiny
group is interesting because they're
oops
rarely involves humility about the field
or about the knowledge it's just oh we
went a little too far with the
free-market thing and we didn't really
think about the political implications
and
oops we really didn't realize it might
generate plutocracy rather than pure
competitive markets and that it would
produce such extreme inequality Oh
Piketty told us about that but now we
realize we did know but still what you
need to do is listen to us because we've
learned our lessons we'll get the next
phase right they need that oops to be
deep really deep on the other hand we
look at the climate scientists and we
live off of every drop of what they
deliver to us in their knowledge about
interconnected systems that have been
parceled out to biology chemistry
physics oceanography etc because the
climate scientists are the ones who
understand those things are all
connected we want that expertise so even
there I think we bear a tension that
that requires us as we think about
building different kinds of universities
or pressing against the university all
together to demand something or to deal
with to be more politically efficacious
in the world even there I think we have
to be careful about not simply putting
things in categories of wrong and right
we want to transform expertise we want
to build humility into it and we want it
to leave its conventional categories and
safe spaces we want it to go into a
worldliness and an encounter with its
limitations and and then you know I
think that's what's happened at its best
in the medical field as it finally
understood that psyche and soma are
connected as it finally understood that
acupuncture is not just you know some
mad traditional pre-scientific thing but
actually does everything from from
relieve pain to produce sleep to to
soothe things that no other form of
medical approach can engage that that
humility in expertise and that knowledge
that that reckoning that we need to
continue to develop knowledge and
order to be efficacious politically
that's where we need conjoining not new
forms of opposition enough i think we're
overdue for coffee professor Brown for
every thank you for no no oh sorry I'm
sorry I was looking at that clock and I
thought you're not letting us know he's
not letting us ambitious we're still on
the clock
this question may take too much of an
answer I don't know and excuse me for
writing it out I just wanted to make
sure I was succinct and clear so I'd
like to ask professor Brown what she
might say about MOX favors ideas about
his swamp and the role that they might
play or that they do play in this
Islamic phobia of the present Salameh
phobia is based among other things on
the idea that the Islamic world can be
defined as a self-contained civilization
with essential inherent features that
set it apart essential features that are
bad that set it apart from other
civilizations and particularly that of
the West or at least that's one form of
Orientalism yes and many have argued
that Max Weber played an important role
in the development of such ideas I will
quote briefly from Ahmad Armando
Salvatore's book Islam and the political
discourse of modernity according to Marx
Weber Islam lacked a concept of
civilization in ethical dimensions it
could not produce the spiritual
inwardness conducive to the mastery of
the outer world in the form of
capitalism and this failure was linked
to its character as a war religion the
way in which favors kind of thinking has
been embodied in the intellectual
history of the modern West is reflected
in a crude remark by a claude
lévi-strauss intrest repeat in 1955 and
I quote Islam is a barrack room religion
appealing to anxious men who make up for
feelings of inferior
by jealousy pride and heroism the
traditional forms of sublimation with
which the Arab soul has always been
associated well you're right my my
response will be brief and I suspect you
might have something to say as well
Islam probably been treated worse than
the Jews in the history of modern
political thought by modern I simply
mean 18th century forward it always gets
identified whether by John Stuart Mill
or by Weber Burke I mean yeah I was
gonna start with them yes the 20th
century as as as this kind of
tribalistic hyper masculine us it's it's
it's it's it's the displacement of
everything Sayid said about Orientalism
on steroids it's the displacement of all
that we imagine we have ejected from the
West that we do not have here on to this
one space in place and that intellectual
contribution I think cannot be said to
be causal in the current surge of
Islamophobia but certifying and
legitimize legitimating of it without
question and I offer no defense of Weber
in that regard or in a larger sense any
defense of his treatment of religion
more generally I just can't that's
that's not the Weber I was reading for
or reading now that does that also have
a place and a play in the Weber that I
am reading the masculinism certainly
does the rationalism certainly does the
belief in our scientific city that all
those you know enlightenment values -
the emancipatory promise certainly does
so that's where I severely part company
him did you want to add no no job I
would only observe that the question of
treating any community with delicacy and
grace is a question that these
universities are especially good at
correcting and thinking forward on and
at this university they're extraordinary
contemporary scholars of Islam the
question have they corrected
what is so deep inside of us which is to
divide and to compare I think what I
found moving about when these particular
descriptions a day of encountering favor
encountering a conservative other who
she is not and what would it be to take
totally deeply passionately seriously
that that person has the multiplicity
the contradiction of prejudice racism
confusion that we possess she possesses
and then to encounter fully what does
that look like and what merits and other
to do that I think that's a moving
depiction of what at best we hope to
stage in these rooms I'm glad we made
room for that last question thank you
thank you there is a light lunch served
for everybody everybody's invited it's
in room 108 right down the hall where
you can continue the conversation that's
the first thing I wanted to say the
second thing is Wendy Brown this has
been an extraordinary three days thank
you so very much thank all three of our
speakers but Wendy in particular thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and I also want to thank my host
for inviting me and to thank the two of
you for really rare and wonderful
conversation these things don't always
work as we all know we've all been in
the ones that haven't worked and this
one did and thank you for continuing to
show up
[Music]